hallo in dem amerikanischen science
fiction film precious geht es wie der
titel schon klar macht und passagiere
ein raumschiff namens avalon ist
unterwegs zu einem planeten ziemlich
weit entfernt von der erde 5000 menschen
wollen dort ein neues leben aufbauen
eine neue welt erschaffen die reisholz
100 die arbeit dauernd das ist aber für
einen film natürlich jetzt keine
ausreichenden geschichte und deswegen
passiert das was zu erwarten ist nämlich
einer diese passagiere wird
unvorhergesehen früher war dann haben
wir die erde verlassen
vor etwa 30 jahren
die spitze straftat erste jahr paket und
dann passiert das was aus dieser
geschichte erst einen klassischen
hollywood film macht der braucht eine
partnerin um so gesellt sich eben eine
frau zu ihm die gründe soll nicht
verraten werden wenn wir sind sehr sehr
wichtig für das zentrale motiv der
geschichte nämlich wie diese beiden
miteinander auskommen
sehr schön hast lang wieder brav bist du
fragst und warum hast du dein leben auf
der erde ausgegeben loreley ist ein name
der weiblichen hauptfigur sind wir
gespielt von jennifer lawrence und ihr
partner kind preston wird von chris
pratt gespielt und wer ein bisschen mit
dem heutigen hollywood krise vertraut
ist weiß zuvor zwei ganz große namen
ziehen
mit einem wort wär's mit einem traumbad
unüblicherweise es gibt einen kleinen
hauch von selbstironie aber im grunde
ist es eine recht erwachsene rollen
interpretation wenn die geschichte die
ergebnisse der sie eine romantische
komödie darstellen können ernsthaften
kern und das ist eben die frage was
macht die liebe wenn sie sozusagen
isoliert ist und wir gleichzeitig
endlose möglichkeiten offen stehen
bitte
das hat mich am besten daran gefällt ist
dass passengers auf dem grund dass wir
eine der ältesten geschichten echt
abendländischen überlieferung erkennen
lässt das ist recht deutlich adam und
eva die wir hier sehen
ich geh zu maschinen bekommst du es
hänge ich brauche deine hilfe
und wenn man das dann noch ein bisschen
mit zudem des pächters ein auch auf dem
ebenen bis einzige kino sind ganz
gelungen ist dann hat man sich mit einer
ganz guten mischung von vaters zu tun
und auch mit einem film der neben aller
action auf eine gewisse weise doch sehr
weit ist und der deswegen auf vielen
ebenen teig zu empfehlen ist
[Musik]